♪ [music] ♪
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal. Naked. Large brain. Long the
master of fire, tools, and language, but
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable, yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand
down knowledge. We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and how
we got here. An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
- [Pascal] I hope that this afternoon's
excellent presentations have convinced you
that the skin is very much worthwhile as a
target of anthropogony, the study of human
origins. Skin is also very powerful. In
some places more than others. We are not
comfortable with nakedness depending on
where we grew up or when we grew up.
So we like to cover skin and we learn
today that this creates a new ecosystem
for some interesting animals. And we've
also learned that we have changed our
colors many times in different directions.
And our hair, shape and color. It is fair
to say that skin is our largest organ. We
have an ideal model, the wet suit, in
southern California. Two millimeters,
about the thickness of your skin, and the
surface of one of these banners, about two
square meters. It is a self-healing
barrier. It provides protection. It
provides defense, thermal regulation and
energy in form of the brain battery and in
form of your first food. Naturally, for
two and a half years until average weening
age, before agriculture. We synthesize
vitamins there. It's a very important
sensory organ. It's an ecosystem in more
ways than one. And it has strong signaling
value. It even signals our internal state
of mind when we blush or flush, either
saying a lie or being embarrassed. More so
if you are melanically challenged as us
people coming from northern places where
we lost melanin. So I think we have many,
many things to discover in the future
study of skin, and I urge you to stay here
for the question answer session. But I'd
like to, for those who might leave before
the answer session, I'd like to thank all
of you in the audience. To those who made
the symposium possible. The symposium
chairs, my co-chair Nina Jablonski, our
featured speakers, our individual
supporters and, of course, all of you for
attending. So I look forward to question
session and I think my
co-chair Nina Jablonski
will address the first set of questions.
- [Nina] We have, not surprisingly, some
wonderful questions that have come
forward. A question first for Doctor
Gallo. Since the sterile wound has more
inflammation, should we be scrubbing
people with betadine et cetera
pre-operatively or not?
- [Dr. Gallo] Well that's an excellent
question and it brings to distinction
between pathogens and commensal organisms.
First of all, scrubbing with betadine does
not sterilize the skin. There's still a
tremendous number of microbes that
persist, but betadine does
minimize the number of pathogens,
so absolutely we should scrub.
- [Nina] That was clear enough.
Two good questions for Doctor Sawka. The
first, does the scalp and hair
play a big role in heat loss?
- [Dr. Sawka] It does in cold
environments. You have a tremendous amount
of heat loss through the head because
that's the exposed area and you don't get
the constriction. But in a warm
environment you don't have any exceptional
amount of heat loss through the head. It's
predominantly your skin of your torso and
these areas are overlying
the active muscle.
- [Nina] Hold on, there's another
question. A second question. Many cultures
believe that eating hot chilies in hot
weather causes a cooling effect from
sweating. Is this valid?
- [Dr. Sawka] Not that I'm aware of but...
- [Nina] Not surprising, we have a group
of people absolutely obsessed with the
microbiome, and so we have a large number
of questions, and some of these might be
shared between Richard and Rob so you guys
can sort of divvy them up. Do chemical
additions to western biomes negatively
impact our health? You've covered a
comparison, but I'm wondering about the
implications of research like this.
So I think the effect of
chemical additives.
- [Dr. Knight] So we saw that data for the
first time last night. We haven't had time
to fully look into the health
implications. So that's certainly the
direction we would like to take the
research though.
- [Nina] With respect to the fecal
microbiome, your studies show that it
matures at about two and a half years.
This coincides with the weening time of
the Hadza. Is there a mismatch between
early weening in the west and the gut
microbe maturation at two
and a half years?
- [Dr. Knight] That's a very interesting
question. We've looked across culturally
the specific effect of weening and what we
see is the maturation effect overall,
although it's affected by weening,
children who were weened at different ages
still follow the overall pattern of
maturation. So probably it's not going to
be an issue to ween earlier. Again, none
of this data existed three years ago, so
the kinds of perspective or ...
studies you'd want to see have not yet
been done. One thing I'll note briefly is
that because the technology to do this has
dropped in cost so rapidly, a huge number
of studies are possible now that weren't
possible a few years ago. So it's a
tremendous opportunity for students
getting into this field.
- [Nina] What is known about
the skin microbiome of
populations with great longevity?
- [Dr. Knight] Nothing.
That's another great example of one of
those projects that you could do now but
you couldn't have done a few years ago.
- [Nina] Does eating probiotic food, is
that useful for the microbiome after
taking antibiotics? Can we regain
our microbiome?
- [Dr. Knight] Yes. A number of different
probiotics have been clinically validated
for post antibiotic diarrhea, so in
general any of those probiotics or eating
live yogurt, has been
shown to be beneficial
in several different clinical studies.
- [Nina] Does chlorine in swimming pools
act like antibiotics on the microbiome?
- [Dr. Knight] Great question. No data.
- [Nina] There we go Richard.
- [Dr. Knight] Maybe Rich has data.
- [Dr. Sawka] No.
- [Nina] That's it, thank you. A question
for Sarah Miller. How different are the
human and chimpanzee
mammary glands?
- [Sarah] So I don't think there's been a
lot of comparative studies on that, but
they, in each case, there are two mammary
glands which are pectoral. So the basic
structure is the same, but I'm not aware
of any detailed investigations. But they
would be interesting.
- [Nina] A question for anyone, but I'll
take a stab at it myself. When, during
evolution, did the sclera of human eyes
become white rather than dark? We know
that this is something that is a physical
distinction of humans compared to
non-human primates, including
our closest relatives.
I would think that this occurred quite
early in our evolution, and that it was an
important part of our long distance
signaling and visual display adaptation.
It's hard to say exactly when this
could've occurred, but certainly much of
human facial gestures and many aspects of
human gestural vocabulary are visible from
a great distance, or at least from several
meters. And I would think that there was
probably selection for white sclera for
increased visibility and for understanding
the direction of gaze at the same time.
- [Pascal] Traditionally, high incidences
of neural tube defects have been found in
northern latitudes such as the UK and
northern China. How did this correlate to
UV damage folic acid?
- [Nina] High prevalence of neural tube
defects in these populations is associated
with extreme low folate diets. And so
there was probably minimal amounts of
ultraviolet radiation induced loss of
folate in those populations. Rather there
has been historically, and fairly
recently, tremendously low folate in the
diets. Folate comes from fresh green
vegetables, citrus fruits and whole grains
and we know that in populations that are
eating very highly refined grains with not
a lot of fresh fruit and veg, that there's
a lot of folate deficiency.
- [Pascal] I have a question for Mark
Stoneking. Does your study of body lice
not shed light on the evolution of
sleeping blankets? Skins of animals, not
clothing. This seems more likely in light
of the 40,000-year evidence of needles.
Fossil needles.
- [Mark] Yeah we don't know for sure
exactly what the evolution of clothing
involved, but it seems reasonable to think
that humans would have started out with
wearing skins of animals, which would have
probably been similar to the hair. May
have facilitated the movement of lice into
the hides or skins that humans were
wearing. And then you later have the
production of real woven clothing and so
forth. I don't think humans were weaving
that much 70,000 years ago, so...
- [Pascal] Another question for Sarah
Miller. At what point in evolution did
humans develop only two mammary glands?
We kind of touched upon this so I
would...what is the implication of
supernumerary nipples?
- [Sarah] So I don't think it's known at
what point humans developed two mammary
glands. But it's assumed that it happened
perhaps in response to the decreased
number of babies that humans have compared
with some other species. In terms of
supernumerary nipples, so I talked a
little bit about how the mammary or milk
line is an important embryological
precursor of mammary glands and this is
found in humans as well. And supernumerary
nipples often develop along those lines.
They can, in fact, very small ones, can
even develop during pregnancy. And this is
thought to be due to mammary tissue that
has somehow got left behind during the
formation of the mammary glands.
So some circumstantial evidence and some
of our own unpublished data suggests that
during the formation of the embryonic
mammary gland, cells actually move along
the mammary line and end up in the
positions where the mammary gland will
form. So if those migrations fail or
happen abnormally this can leave behind a
little bit of tissue that could develop a
supernumerary nipple, either during a
re-genesis or even later in life in
response to hormones.
- [Pascal] Thank you. If you don't mind, I
have a question. A follow up question. Do
we have any information on the age of the
permanent breast in humans as opposed to
chimpanzees and bonobos, where breasts are
not permanently enlarged?
- [Sarah] Yeah, I'm not aware of any
evidence about that but that doesn't mean
there isn't any. They may...
somebody may know.
- [Pascal] Thank you. And one last
question for Ron Knight. And this is the
question whether breast fed babies or
formula fed babies differ
in the gut microbiota.
- [Dr. Knight] Yes. There's been several
studies showing that, and in general the
microbial diversity in the gut is higher
with breast feeding. There's also some
suggestion in the literature that breast
feeding may ameliorate the effects of
early life antibiotics or
C section delivery.
- [Pascal] Thank you very much.
I think that's it for questions.
- [Male Voice 1] I have a follow-up for
Rob. Rob, you mentioned in the C section,
the effects on the microbiome. Does that
have any kind of noticeable health effects
in later life?
- [Dr. Knight] So we're not sure whether
the noticeable health effects of C section
in later life are mediated by the
microbiome yet. So whenever C section
affects the microbiome, we know that C
section affects the risk of several
diseases including atopic dermatitis,
let's see...food allergies, pet allergies
I think are on that list, obesity, asthma.
What we don't know for sure is whether the
mechanism by which C section affects those
conditions is via the changes in the
microbiome, although we know mostly from
animal model work with some evidence in
humans that all of those conditions have
been linked to the microbiome. So the
links that exist are between C section and
disease, C section and the microbiome and
microbiome and disease. But we don't know
if the specific mechanism of action of the
C section is via those particular
changes in the microbiome yet.
Does that make sense?
- [Pascal] Okay, so this concludes our
first ever CARTA symposium on the human
skin. I look forward to a future one.
Thank you all very much for being here
today, and thanks to all the speakers for
the excellent presentations.
♪ [music] ♪